we're joined live this morning by mary
beth seawall president and ceo of the
vegas chamber
to talk about what's in our business
good morning mary beth how you doing
this morning
good morning john i'm awesome how are
you i'm doing
delightful as we talked about so let's
uh let's explore more about reopening
las vegas and the boost to local
businesses we focus a lot on the casinos
of course in the resort area
but what are you seeing and hearing from
businesses all around the valley about
what it's been like now the capacity and
restrictions are being lifted
well i would agree with what jeremy
aguero said you know there is
nothing bad about opening uh be clear
about that
it's a challenge though one of the
biggest challenges that we're hearing
from our members and
and all employers across the state it
are the challenges in hiring folks
because they're
still receiving their unemployment
benefits and
so it makes it challenging for for the
companies and restaurants and
retailers alike to to hire folks so that
they can
keep up with the increased demand
there's such a surge in demand and vegas
is open for business we'll make no
mistake about that
and that's exciting um it's just that
these employers desperately need people
to come back to work
what can employers do though to try and
entice people to get
maybe either back into the workforce or
or to transition into different kinds of
employment
whether it's increasing wages increasing
benefits i know there have been lots of
discussions as you know in carson city
with regards to the minimum wage
what can employers do to try and hire
people they need
yeah there are several things that
employers are doing to
to bring those individuals back to work
some in some cases they're giving
um the extra benefits to come back to
work they're giving a bonus
uh to folks to come back to work so um
extra you know time off and things like
that just to get
individuals to to be interested in
returning to their jobs and so
that's something that is it continues to
be a challenge because we know that
demand is increasing in las vegas
and uh it's extremely exciting we've got
world of concrete as you said coming
back and so
um the the increased demand is just
wonderful to see
and as long as we can get people to come
back to work uh
you know i know i was talking with uh
the golden nugget
the other day and they're looking for
housekeepers to come back to work and so
they're looking for ways to
attract those individuals to come back
to their jobs and we're also looking at
upskilling and reskilling some of these
individuals so that
so that they can be more prepared for
other opportunities as well
just to finish on this discussion is
there a concern on your part of
sort of las vegas getting ahead of its
skis a little bit when it comes to
supply and demand there's so much demand
but if there isn't that supply of
workforce that vegas might
the valley might get ahead of itself a
little bit well i i think
you know there are always concerns we
have to be very smart
and um you know we have to really make
sure that we
are prepared and in some cases you'll
see
longer lines and things like that so so
there are challenges with the increased
demand
but i think overall um employers across
the state
and especially in southern nevada are
doing an excellent job of
being being very creative about how
we're handling that increased demand
the legislative session just wrapped up
up in carson city it was a little bit of
a challenge to be there in person i know
but
let's talk about some of the major bills
quickly that have been
passed by the legislature on the
governor's desk
and the impact on local business well it
was this was one of the most daunting
legislative sessions i've
personally ever seen it was there were a
lot of proposals that if they would have
passed would have significantly harmed
employers and small businesses across
the state
so our job was more important than ever
this year and as you said it was tough
because we weren't able to be
in the building at least until the very
end there
and so you know it was just a very
challenging time and there were a lot of
new dynamics
in carson city as well it was hard to
engage with lawmakers
there were a lot of special interest
groups that were pushing for proposals
and policies that also would have
uh you know hurt economic recovery and
things like that so
um we we saw a lot of proposals that
were
solutions in search of a problem quite
frankly john so
um this was tough but overall the vegas
chamber was
pleased with the outcome a lot of
positive bills passed uh for education
and so forth
so for those reasons it was very good
well mary beth thank you very much for
joining us
usually when people leave the
legislative session there is good and
bad for
both sides of the political party so we
appreciate you joining us good luck with
the recovery and we'll keep in touch as
well as
we get in your business